when you're sitting in the stands of the
big arena the sights and sounds of a
major sporting event can be a real
thrill but they can also overwhelm
especially those with autism and similar
challenges now there's a growing
movement to fix that Dana Jacobson has
the story Dana good morning good morning
tomorrow's NFL Pro Bowl will be the
first to cater to the needs of people
with sensory issues but across the
country stadiums and arenas are
addressing those needs for every game
and event in large part because of the
experience of one family from Akron Ohio
a basketball game a hockey game seems
like an easiest thing to go to as a
family but it's not for you right I
think that it's challenging from the
moment the anxiety of the unknown where
are we going what are we doing to
getting here in parking and finding a
spot over the crowds getting in and
that's before you get to your seat Amy
and Jeff Bellis know going to sporting
events with their autistic son Carson
can be more anxiety filled than exciting
large crowds and loud noises can be
overwhelming Tim still in February 2016
they decided to give a hockey game with
person a shot it was Autism Awareness
night and we thought what a great
opportunity what ports at Center lose
puck high slot justice the Cleveland
monsters of the American Hockey League
we're welcoming autistic fans and their
families to a game at its shared home
with the Cleveland Cavaliers Quicken
Loans Arena also known as the Q but when
the Bellis has arrived they felt
anything but welcome hello my name is
Carson twelve-year-old Carson can't
speak and uses an electronic device
which he wears around his neck to
communicate he had trouble and going
through security and not the security
guard not understanding what Carson's
device was or what it was used for what
happened we're actually told that he
couldn't come through security with that
and Kristen got a little anxious and so
then the security guard he looked at me
and he said that we needed to get
control to get control of that child so
how did that make you feel defeated Amy
couldn't let it go so she took to social
media
launching this tweet treated very poorly
by the queue security last night for
Autism Awareness night a message that
reverberated throughout the arena I felt
like I you know missed an opportunity on
a professional level you know for us to
be better than not Amy's complaint got
the attention of Antony Bonavita senior
vice president for facility operations
at the Q the Bellis experienced hit home
for Bonavita his son Dominic is also on
the autism spectrum you know a personal
level if I got him back ultimately he
falls on me Bona Vita reached out to the
Bella's family what did they say when
they reached out of course initially
apologizing but then they were they just
listened and I just gave them some
suggestions the things that I was
thinking of I wanted to make sure they
were gonna follow through this really
needs to be done this can't happen again
the Q responded quickly working with the
Cleveland Clinic on training for staff
the goal to become more inclusive for
those with sensory issues ranging from
autism to PTSD why was that so important
for the Q you know for any business you
want to be as broad as you can to
attract as many different people as you
can that's just good business but we're
more than that what we mean to this city
means more than a business element we
want it to be more about my son or your
song or anybody else's parent or
somebody has PTSD to know that they have
a home and a place that they can come
now when a family like the bella says
comes to the q they can pick up a
sensory friendly bag it includes items
like fidget toys a weighted lap pad and
noise cancelling headphones there's also
a sensory room a designated space away
from the action that serves as an escape
if the sights and sounds in the arena
get to be too much compressing a moat
but inside soothing bubble art on the
walls
and tactile displays that can calm a
mind that's been overstimulated even as
we were walking right now you can hear
how loud the traffic in the queue can
thank Michelle Kong for the changes she
and her husband Julian Maha are
physicians and the parents of two boys
including a 10 year old who is autistic
they created a nonprofit called culture
city focused on a mission of inclusion
we saw how having a diagnosis like
autism it truly made the families
isolated from the community so the
genesis of culture city really was us
saying how can we change the culture of
a community to one where it is inclusive
to all individuals regardless of their
challenges culture city started by
helping their local zoo in Birmingham
Alabama becomes sensory inclusive in
2014 but perhaps their biggest impact
has been sports venues culture city has
helped 15 NBA and NHL arenas and one NFL
stadium becomes sensory aware their
first was the Q so what's it like now
coming to games with the sensory
awareness room you feel welcome to sit
and look around and know that we can do
what other families can do this is
pretty awesome and it really is minimal
cost for those rooms and the idea that
maybe just one more fan can go to a
concert or go to a game it's all the
difference and you read the emails from
these people that were able to it's
incredible good for them
those kids deserve a shot at seeing some
sports in an arena I think we all need a
room with soothing Bubba we do we do